so uh one interesting sort of tangent I
would love to take on this because you
mentioned this in the essay about
nuclear which was also
I mean you don't shy away from a little
bit of uh of a spicy take
so uh uh Robert Oppenheimer famously
said now I am become death the destroyer
of worlds as he witnessed the first
detonation of a nuclear weapon on July
16th 1945 and you write an interesting
historical perspective uh quote recall
that John Von Neumann responded to Robin
Robert oppenheimer's famous handwringing
about the role of creating nuclear
weapons which you note helped end World
War II and prevent World War III
with some people confess guilt to claim
credit for the sin and you also
mentioned that true moon was harsher
after meeting Oppenheimer he said that
don't let that crybaby be in here again
real quick real quick by the way
promoting it from Dean Atchison uh oh
boy because Oppenheimer didn't just say
the famous line yeah he then spent years
going around basically moaning him you
know going on TV and going into going
into the White House and basically like
just like doing this hair shirt you know
thing self you know this sort of
self-critical like oh my God I can't
believe how awful I am so he's the the
he's widely considered
perhaps of the because of the Hang
ringing is the father of the atomic bomb
um this is a binomous criticism of him
as he tried to have his cake and eat it
too like he wanted to in in
soyman of course a very different kind
of personality and he's just like yeah
this is like an incredibly useful thing
I'm glad we did it yeah well if I know
him as as widely
um credit as being one of the smartest
humans of the 20th century there's
certain certain people everybody says
like this is the smartest person I've
ever met when they've met him anyway uh
that doesn't mean smart doesn't mean
wise
I would love to sort of can you make the
case both for and against the critique
of Oppenheimer here because we're
talking about nuclear weapons boy do
they seem dangerous well so the critique
goes deeper and I left this out here's
the real substance I left it out because
I didn't want to dwell on nukes in my AI
paper
but here's the deeper thing that
happened and I'm really curious this
movie coming out this summer I'm really
curious to see how far he pushes this
because this is the real drama in the
story which is it wasn't just a question
of our nukes good or bad it was a
question of should Russia also have them
um and what what actually happened um
was Russia got the America invented the
bomb Russia got the bomb they got the
bomb through Espionage they got American
and you know they got American
scientists and foreign scientists
working on the American project some
combination of the two uh basically gave
the Russians the designs for the bomb
and that's how the Russians got the bomb
um there's this dispute to this day of
oppenheimer's role in that
um if you read all the histories the
kind of composite picture and by the way
we now know a lot actually about Soviet
Espionage in that era because there's
been all this Declassified material in
the last 20 years that actually shows a
lot of a lot of very interesting things
but if you kind of read all the
histories which you kind of get is
Oppenheimer himself probably was not a
he probably did not hand over the
nuclear secrets himself however he was
close to many people who did including
family members and there were other
members of the Manhattan Project who
were Russian Soviet assets and did hand
over the bomb and so the view of that
Oppenheimer and people like him had that
this thing is awful and terrible and oh
my God and you know all this stuff you
could argue you fed into this ethos at
the time that resulted in people
thinking that the Baptists thinking that
the only principal thing to do is to
give the Russians the bomb
um and so the the moral beliefs on this
thing and the public discussion and the
role that the inventors of this
technology play this is the point of
this book when they kind of take on this
sort of public intellectual moral kind
of thing it can have real consequences
right because we live in a very
different world today because Russia got
the bomb than we would have lived in had
they not gotten the bomb right the
entire 20th century second half of 20th
century would have played out very
different had those people not given
Russia the bomb and so the stakes were
very high then the good news today is
nobody's sitting here today I don't
think worrying about like an analogous
situation with respect to like I'm not
really worried that Sam Altman's going
to decide to give you know the Chinese
the design for
yeah although he did just speak at a
Chinese conference which is interesting
but however I don't think I don't think
that's what's at play here but what's at
play here are all these other
fundamental issues around what do we
believe about this and then what laws
and regulations and restrictions are we
going to put on it and and that's where
I draw like a direct straight line and
anyway and my reading of the history on
nukes is like the people who were doing
the full hair shirt public this is awful
this is terrible actually had like
catastrophically bad results uh from
from taking those views um and that's
what I'm worried it's gonna happen again
but is there a case to be made that you
really need to wake the public up to the
dangers of nuclear weapons when they
were first dropped like really like
educate them on like this is extremely
dangerous and destructive weapon I think
the education kind of happened quick and
early like how it was pretty obvious we
dropped one bomb and destroyed an entire
city
yeah so 80 000 people then what uh and
look but I don't like the reporting of
that you can report that in all kinds of
ways of course you can you can do all
kinds of Slants like war is horrible war
is terrible you can do you can make it
seem like nuclear the use of nuclear
weapons is just a part of war and all
that kind of stuff something about the
reporting in the discussion of nuclear
weapons resulted in us being
terrified in awe of the power of nuclear
weapons and that potentially
fed in a positive way towards the the
game theory of mutual issue of
Destruction well so this gets to what
actually how let's get to what some of
us Playing devil's advocate here yeah
yeah sure of course let's get to what
actually happened and then kind of back
into that so what what actually happened
I believe and again I think this is a
reasonable reading of history is what
actually happened was nukes then
prevented World War III and they
prevented World War III through the game
theory of mutually assured destruction
had nukes not existed right there would
have been no reason why the cold war did
not go hot right and then they're and
then you know and the military planners
at the time right thought both on both
sides thought that there was going to be
World War III on the planes of Europe
and they thought there was going to be
like 100 million people dead right it
was like the most obvious thing in the
world to happen
right and it's the dog that didn't bark
right like it may be like the best
single net thing that happened in the
entire 20th century is it like that
didn't happen yeah actually just at that
point you say a lot of really brilliant
things it hit me just as you were saying
it
I don't know why it hit me for the first
time but we got two Wars in a span of
like uh 20 years
like we could have kept getting more and
more world wars more and more ruthless
it actually you could have had a US
versus Russia War you could have by the
way you have you ever there's another
hypothetical scenario the other
hypothetical scenario is the Americans
got the bomb the Russians didn't
right and then America's the big dog and
then maybe America would have had the
capability to actually roll back the
Iron Curtain
I don't know whether that would have
happened but like it's entirely possible
right and and and the act of these
people who had these moral positions
about because they could forecast they
could model they could forecast the
future of how the signals would get used
made a horrific mistake because they
basically ensured that the Iron Curtain
would continue for 50 years longer than
it would have otherwise and again like
these are counterfactuals I don't know
that that's what would have happened but
like
[Music]
the decision to hand the bomb over was a
big decision
made by people who were very full of
themselves
yeah but so me as an America me as a
person that loves America I also wonder
if us was the only ones with the nuclear
weapons
uh that was the argument for handing the
book that was the was uh the guys who
the guys who handed over the bomb that
was actually their moral argument yeah I
would probably not hand it over to I
would be careful about the regimes you
handed over to maybe you give it to like
the British or something
or like uh like a democratically elected
government well look there are people to
this day who think that those by Sophie
spies did the right thing because they
created a balance of Terror as opposed
to the us having just and by the way let
me let me balance of Terror let's tell
the full version that's such a sexy ring
to it okay so the full version of the
story is John Von Neumann's a hero of
both Heroes of mine the full version of
the story is he advocated for a first
try so when the U.S had the bomb and
Russia did not he advocated for he said
we need to strike them right now
strike Russia yeah
yes
because he said World War III is
inevitable
um he was very hardcore uh he his his
theory was
um his theory was World War Three is
inevitable we're definitely going to
have a world war three the only way to
stop world war three is we have to take
them out right now and we have to take
them out right now before they get the
bomb because this is our last chance
now again like is this an example of
philosophers and politics I don't know
if that's in there or not but this is in
the standard no but it is it meaning
exactly this is on the other side so so
most of the case studies most of the
case studies in books like this are the
crazy people on the left yeah
um Von Neumann is a story arguably of
the crazy people on the right
um yeah stick to Computing John well
this is the thing and this is this is
the general principle it's getting push
back to our core thing which is like I
don't know whether any of these people
should be making any of these calls yeah
because there's nothing in either Von
Neumann's background or oppenheimer's
background or any of these people's
background that qualifies them as moral
authorities yeah well this actually
brings up the point of Nai who are the
good people to to reason about the
morality the ethics the outside of these
risks outside like the more complicated
stuff that you you agree on is you know
this will go into the hands of bad guys
and all the kinds of ways they'll do is
is interesting and dangerous
um is dangerous in interesting
unpredictable ways and who is the right
person who are the right kinds of people
to make decisions how respond to it is
attack people so the history of these
fields this is what he talks about in
the book The History of these fields is
that the the competence and capability
and intelligence and training and
accomplishments of senior scientists and
technologists working on a technology
and then being able to then make moral
judgments in the use of the technology
that direct record is terrible that
tracker that track record is like
catastrophically bad
um and the people just illuminate the
people that developed that technology
are usually not going to be the right
people
well why would they so the claim is of
course they're the knowledgeable ones
but the problem is they've spent their
entire life in a lab right they're not
theologians but so what you find what
you find when you read when you read
this when you look at these histories
which you find is they generally are
very thinly informed on history on
sociology on on on theology on morality
ethics they tend to manufacture their
own world views from scratch they tend
to be very sort of thin
um
they're not remotely the arguments that
you would be having if you got like a
group of Highly qualified theologians or
philosophers or you know um well let me
uh sort of uh as The Devil's Advocate
takes a sip of whiskey say that
I I agree with uh
with that but also it seems like the
people who are doing kind of the ethics
departments and these tax tech companies
go sometimes the other way yes
they're not nuanced on the on history or
theology or this kind of stuff they it
almost becomes a kind of outraged
activism towards
um
directions that don't seem to be
grounded in history and humility and
Nuance it's again drenched with
arrogance so so definitely I'm not sure
which is worse oh no they're both bad
yeah so definitely not them either so
but I guess oh look this is a hard yeah
it's a hard problem that's not a problem
and this goes back to where we started
which is okay who has the truth and it's
like well
um you know like how do Society survive
at like truth and how do we figure these
things out and like our elected leaders
play some role in it
you know we all play some role in it
um there have to be some set of public
intellectuals at some point that bring
you know rationality and judgment
humility to it yeah those people are few
and far between we should probably prize
them very highly yes celebrate humility
in our public leaders